hey there fellow townscapers and welcome
back to the channel thank you so much
for stopping by as always is greatly
appreciated if you have never been to my
channel before welcome welcome welcome
and thank you so much for stopping by to
see me today so we're just going to get
down to the matter at hand i was today
years old when i found out you could
play townscaper and walk through your
builds on your web browser and it just
blew my mind so just couldn't believe it
today i woke up to the news that you
could walk through your townscaper
builds on the web browser by using a
tool called 3scaper if you ever want to
explore your builds in first person you
can export your obj files and import
them into this browser tool the tool was
created by millie harvey and you can
find it via their github page the link
will also be in the description it's
really really awesome i had a lot of fun
playing with it just walking through one
of my builds and being able to stand on
the balconies and just walk through the
pathways and i tried to load a floating
build but i could not reach it it was
just too high in the air my floating
bills are always pretty high so i made a
smaller one that was lower and it worked
out perfectly i
i love this this tool is just amazing
and it is truly chef's kiss if you will
uh if you own townscaper i highly
recommend that you try it out for
yourself also i learned today that you
could demo townscaper on the internet i
thought that was pretty cool because you
can actually try it out before you buy
it in order to access it you want to go
to oscar stahlberg's website and you can
always click the link in the description
below can also use the link found in the
article that i read this morning as well
as the link for three skateboard i think
this demo is pretty cool the grid is
small but if you like it a lot and you
want to expand your demo build you can
always buy a copy of townscaper they
actually have links in the demo if you
open up the ui there is a list of
platforms that townscaper is available
on and you can just click on whichever
one you prefer and it will take you to
the marketplace and then you can
purchase townscaper after you buy your
copy of townscaper you can save your
build on the browser by copying it from
the browser's address bar there's
actually a clipboard code in the address
bar so you would copy that code and then
you would load it into your copy or your
version of townscaper and from there you
can expand your build i was playing with
this earlier today this is the footage
from my gameplay it's really awesome i
think it's really nice that he put it on
the browser for us to just demo and just
play with a little bit and it'll come in
handy for those who don't have mobile
but are on someone else's computer and
if you have the itch and you want to
play and you can't get to your computer
well there it is on the browser so yeah
that's it for me today it was a pretty
short video i just wanted to make this
video and put it out there to anyone
else who's interested in viewing
townscaper from a first person point of
view or if you want to demo townscaper
before you buy it this is your
opportunity the link is in the
description below please share this
video with your friends and family who
enjoy townscapers i would greatly
appreciate it if you enjoyed this video
and you thought it was helpful please
like the video as it would help me out
in the algorithm please subscribe to the
channel so it helped me out a lot
subscribing to my channel is a free way
to support me and it's the most
important part of supporting me and i
would appreciate it a lot so anyways
thank you guys so much i'm glad you guys
stopped by today and i will see you all
next time
[Music]